only we've got the gold i want the
golden ticket
to go behind the scenes
we really just wanted to bring a lot of
joy and the set is gorgeous it's
colorful it's psychedelic it's just
i don't know candy makes the world a
better place doesn't it happy halloween
and welcome to the talk everyone
the ladies of the talk take a trip to
willy wonka's chocolate factory
on this year's halloween episode which
airs friday on cbs
how did you choose your costume well
really i didn't choose the costume the
costume chose me
violet beauregard she turns into a
gigantic blueberry and then they squeeze
her
violet you're turning violet violet why
didn't you go all in and go blue
oh i'm going to go blue kevin fraser
my kids growing up always when they were
naughty i would call them veruca
so it's kind of grown up with us for
years so
i love varuka salt i want it now
i want it and i want it now daddy
[Music]
i also hear you have some special guests
that are going to join you
who are some of the special guests i
could keep a secret camera come on you
can tell me no i cannot
you can tell me no fine i'll just ask
carrie anne
you want to tell me about some of the
surprise guests surprise guests we have
matthew greg gubler who is playing
wait augustus group
and then we have jason ritter okay yeah
who is our charlie
and the hair is perfect